sure sheriff can I ask you sheriff can  you talk then to what was found inside  that hotel room that the gunman used  specifically CBS News is reporting that  there was a camera inside that room was  the gunman recording was the gunman  transmitting that video anywhere else  I'm not aware of any transmission but  there was cameras there was cameras  located in outside of the room and  inside of the room along with the  firearms and he had set up how many  cameras I don't know what purpose do you  think well I anticipate he was looking  for anybody coming to take him into  custody  so essentially you have a recording of  him carrying out this carnage no that's  not essentially what I'm saying that has  been evaluated the FBI took all digital  and electronic evidence into custody and  we are evaluating